only on CBS this morning we are taking
you inside the self-driving car program
operated by way mo a sister company of
Google it's the first time way mo has
allowed cameras in their autonomous
minivans the company is preparing to
launch the nation's first self-driving
taxi service
analysts predict self-driving revenue
will hit a staggering 2.3 trillion
dollars by 2030 with way mo capturing 60
percent of that market Kris Van Cleave
got the first access in Chandler Arizona
good morning we're in the back of a way
mo that's Google's self-driving car
company and this is something you
haven't seen before they've never let
cameras back here but very soon they're
going to start letting the general
public use these hail them like an uber
except one big difference here the car
will be doing the driving not the person
up front I requested the ride Barbara
Adams just used her phone to summon the
self-driving future we're riding with
her to the drugstore in what will soon
be the nation's first autonomous
ride-hailing taxi service for the past
year she's been part of way most
secretive early rider program made up of
more than 400 households in Chandler
Arizona I usually use it for date night
on Saturday night yeah and my favorite
thing is going to the mall yes we wanted
way mo but we wanted that commitment on
safety they've had that commitment J
tips rainy is Chandler's mayor do you
feel like that this is a technology that
changes the way people move it does it
does now we got to keep watching it we
got to keep the safety factors in mind
but if in fact this works like they're
planning it to it's a game changer
hundreds of autonomous driving way mo
vans operate daily within a roughly 100
square mile area for now they typically
have a safety driver up front who can
take control screens inside show the
riders what the way mow sees around it
cameras sensors radar and laser based
lidar allows the on-board computers to
see up to three football fields in every
direction all technology Google
developed itself and closely guards so
it's hard not to notice that the car is
driving itself there is a safety driver
here but the car is doing the steering
and it it does feel a little different
the
self-driving cars a little more hesitant
at points than perhaps a driver would be
at things like approaching a yellow
light for example but for the most part
you pretty much feel like you're in a
car being driven by a person we want to
build the most experienced driver to
keed Ramallah Cana is way Moe's chief
external officer it's actually taken
this 10 million miles over six billion
miles and simulation over thousands and
hundreds of thousands of tests to get to
the answer yes we firmly believe that
self-driving technology can help make
the road safer way moe is also testing
self-driving semis working on public
transit solutions and a way to license
its self-driving technology to big
automakers but it all starts with the
ride-hailing app it'll soon launch in
Arizona is way mo ready for the general
public way mo is ready to give more
people the opportunity to ride in our
cars how's it gone so far it's been
fantastic Samantha Jackson and her 17
year old daughter are way mo early
riders Kyla uses the service almost
daily to get to school and work I get in
air conditionings on so it's nice and
cool and then like I'm just doing my
homework all the way to work the promise
of self-driving cars is to free up
commuters while reducing the 94 percent
of crashes caused by human error but
after last marches deadly collision
between a self-driving Oberer and a
pedestrian only 21 percent of people say
they're willing to ride in a driverless
car how do you combat the concern that's
out there about whether or not
autonomous vehicles are safe enough to
be on the roads we found again and again
and again when people come and they
experience the technology firsthand they
have their own personal transformation
they say oh I get it
while way mo autonomous vehicles have
been involved in crashes usually minor
they've been the fault of people not the
Machine how confident are you that those
cars aren't going to make a mistake
safety is our focus every day at way mo
there is the possibility that there will
be a mistake like there has been in the
self-driving technology space so we
don't walk around laboring under the
delusion
that mistakes won't happen did you ever
worry about the safety of being in a car
that's not driven by a person so I never
really worried about what it was going
to be like to have a autonomous vehicle
handling things and when we were early
drivers it would stop for you know if it
didn't recognize something it would
always stop way mo doesn't tend to
completely remove the safety driver
eventually so there'll be no one up
front at all that app-based ride hailing
service is expected to launch here in
Arizona by the end of the year for CBS
this morning Kris Van Cleave Chandler
Arizona look there's no doubt that
that's the future right there are
concerns about accidents or concerns
about hacking into this technology but
make no mistake between uber between
Google and and way mo this is the future
I sort of feel everybody has to do it or
no one should do it because there's
gonna be people driving cars and you're
gonna have self-driving cars it's gonna
be a little tricky on the roads it's
never coming in New York though because
people really are invested in telling
their drivers where to go that
opportunity can't have that
all right